babylon new york is a quaint village on
the southern shore of long island it's
home to a number of italian restaurants
but there's one family establishment
that needs gordon ramsay's help more
than any other
hi how are you i'm the owner of this
restaurant peter's there's a lot of
stress this place a [ __ ] mess i'm all
over the place it's pretty open right
now what would you like
no one thinks i'm the owner in here they
all think it's my brother cause he's the
host
come on peter help yeah the [ __ ]
wow
there are a lot of restaurant owners
that are married to their business day
and night
but i choose not to live my life that
way i'm the only son that's me
i don't really know who peter thinks he
is
honestly i think he's hoping for a shot
at the next goodfellas movie
just when i thought i was out they
pulled me back in that was a great movie
right yeah that was awesome we're close
family
we're a close family it's a family
business
you understand
come on you [ __ ] up
i believe peter is a core problem of the
restaurant
you know i'm passionate i'm italian i
yell on shannon why is this guy here two
minutes later i'm over it come on let me
hug it out let's hug it out let's hug it
out
he takes advantage of the place can i
have a cappuccino from here please i
take so much pride in myself my
appearance my car my clothes i got sauce
on my suit i take care of myself and it
shows you can put your hands on me i
promise i won't bring you up on charges
you know what i mean
he's not so concerned with the customer
he's more concerned with them noticing
him instead of buying a stove i bought a
suit you know
the tools that we have in the kitchen
right now need to be sharpened
[Music]
there are three ovens down the oven on
the bottom is completely out we have a
broiler that's not working
when i got dressed tonight i felt like i
should have been in florida you know
what i mean the whole family's throwing
everything on tina's shoulders and i
don't think she can handle it okay i
don't give a [ __ ] if it broke but i have
to have a nervous breakdown over a
goddamn candle holder
this restaurant was one of the top
restaurants in the village here
and uh it's just really slowly declined
the restaurant is not making the money
that it was making right now we're not
paying the bills do me a favor go take a
walk how's that gonna take a [ __ ]
walk we're getting phone calls the guy
has not stopped calling and my father's
making the situation worse i feel that
my business is at a pivotal point it
keeps me up at night that i know there
are problems here you made a big mistake
josh
yeah yeah before i lose my life i would
sell the place and i don't want to do
that that's not in my heart
i'm here in babylon in new york to meet
peter from peter's restaurant it's a
family small quaint restaurant and it's
on his ass struggling big time
and he said he's gonna pick me up where
is he
where is he
come on
[Music]
this can't be
him what the [ __ ] is this
peter how you doing gordon good to see
you nice car
how are you dear valentine
welcome to babylon yeah how are you very
well thanking you good great yeah you
look well yeah thank you so do you from
the minute we met it was like superman
arrived you know so i'm very excited
come on in i feel like i'm in hollywood
and what a quaint little uh town so here
it is
welcome peters thank you
fdo
i want to introduce you to my family mom
dad this is gordon ramsay and this is
tina tina
when i first met him like you know i
didn't know how to take him but with
this hair like that i think it was one
of these
crazy foreigners it's your restaurant
peter's it's my name yeah it's mine how
nice all the family working together
absolutely mum dad big brother little
sister when gordon got here i was so
looking forward to meeting him i mean
he's a smart guy he's a good-looking guy
he's charismatic so who's the chef
robert robert robert gordon ramsay how
are you displeasure this is robert
o'sara and you're the head chef i'm the
head chef excellent these are my two
best friends jerry and jerry jerry and
jerry how you doing yeah cheers oh you
know what it is if they don't like the
food they go over jerry and jerry speak
the [ __ ] out of them
i feel honored i've been introduced to
the mob
well this one's gonna be interesting
isn't it fun mate
have you decided yeah i might start with
the crab cake please thank you okay and
then one of my favorites lobster ravioli
very good lovely
thank you everyone i'm sorry your first
name was angelo andrew
gentleman i got uh ramsay's order please
okay here's the crap thank you okay this
is a spicy dijon sauce the cupcakes are
homemade
they are homemade yes thank you enjoy
looks terrible the salad
[Music]
this salad fresh it's all like little
bits in there
like rotten
huh how old is that salad take it back
before something jumps out there i'll
just taste the crab cake
it's rotten there no yes
dad this is ridiculous man look at the
how old is this salad you make me look
like a [ __ ]
um angelo yes i don't want to put you in
an awkward position but that's stone
cold in the middle and that's not fresh
crab meat
that grows
okay i'll let him know yeah
when you come into an italian restaurant
you want to identify that the food is
fresh instantly fruitcake
cold
not a good start
he might knock the ravioli with that
he's gonna knock the ravioli what is he
gonna knock about the ravioli is that
good no yeah from restaurant depot what
do you think yeah
[Music]
thank you well i don't need any parsley
that's not even lobster that's just like
baby food inside gunk who pool garnish
that dish
what who garnished that dish
you gotta be kidding me you put half a
pound of parsley on my plate he said wow
enough parsley on this dish first of all
i put the parsley on and that's my job
and i'll decide what goes on it ain't
your problem yeah but i don't need to
hear criticism which i already know
it's craziness it's chaos at times i can
shoot every person in here gentlemen
it's over
it's over what's going on john the sous
chef is insulted over the parsley
i'm gonna go defuse a fight in this
kitchen right now excuse me
out of here
that's how i like to do it so i did it
my way
do you understand what i'm saying angelo
all the [ __ ] time holy smoke
welcome to babylon
now that gordon has tried the food it's
time for a heart to heart with a
pellegrino family i'd like to be told
the truth
nothing but the truth and the quicker i
get to the truth the quicker i can help
so
manager the way i look at things is
everyone
come in comes in tells everyone
and we appreciate it mom but you're here
you know but you really shouldn't give
input of anything he comes here and
creates more problems
[Music]
it's day two in babylon and gordon has
already discovered that the speciality
of this restaurant is arguing now it's
time to investigate the state of the
kitchen
what's in this one bloody hell
what is in there
bread rolls
bread rocks temperature of the fridge is
not even cold so stuff's rotten
mold
moldy decay
rotten onions yeah they look like
[ __ ] camel's turd
it looks like something out of a [ __ ]
sci-fi movie
oh my god
you eat that it's like the fridge has
dripped all over it the whole thing's
leaking here last year's rainwater
inside the whole thing looks like it's
about to fall down
[Music]
hey
me thanks for coming i'm
very sorry he made something happen i
had to pick something what happened i
had to pick up something that came uh
indirectly to you know inadvertently to
one place this was like an act of god
this morning
okay let me show you uh something that i
hope will open your [ __ ] eyes um tina
angelo as well yeah have a look at this
when was the last time you went inside a
walking fridge to walk in fridge uh i
had a hot flash last weekend a hot flash
what does that mean
i mean i was like hot and i walked in
here for a second
look there's onions growing on top of
onions but it gets worse unfortunately
the whole thing's leaking here
what the [ __ ] is that what is that
i don't know you have taste a chef you
can become famous in the next 24 hours
for [ __ ] poisoning half of babylon
you ought to be [ __ ] ashamed
that is sour and has to be four weeks
old just just just smell that for me no
no just just smell it i just got up yeah
okay just just smell it though tina
[Music]
that's right would we really serve that
no but does it just fall under the
chef's job well where are the [ __ ]
this is your fridge in the middle of
your [ __ ] business can we get out of
here before i catch something yeah i
feel terrible it's like you know telling
somebody telling you your kid is ugly
this is ridiculous here
the walking box is a mess but you know
what that walking box was exactly how we
felt
about working in the kitchen it's like
blame everything on me
make fires in chicago hurricane katrina
9 11 what the [ __ ] i mean i've never
seen something like that stop acting
like a [ __ ] baby i'm not acting like
a baby
guys please clean the place you're
embarrassing me i've never seen
something like this this is unbelievable
before gordon does anything else he
wants to make sure the kitchen is
spotless
how we doing ladies
i believe peter is a core problem of the
restaurant's dysfunction and he isn't
concerned much about anybody else but
himself
[Music]
the kitchen is now cleaner than it's
been in years so gordon can turn his
attention to observing tonight's dinner
service
and reservations what we got booked
we're really uh what do we have some uh
there's nothing in there
business is is rough it's hurt i may
have to sell my watch i've got 20
dollars so it's fake
fake the only thing that's fake is my
teeth
they're [ __ ] wise they're white they
bleach how much that costs
thousands of visit
i just brush mine twice a day
you now
but it goes well with a brown town
well you know somewhat yeah i'd rather
buy a new [ __ ] stove
[Laughter]
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's been such a long time
since i have good equipment here it's
bothering me but there's nothing i can
do about it it's not my restaurant what
doesn't work all these stove tops here
don't work
the broiler doesn't work properly this
oven does not work we use it as storage
we keep our towels and stuff in here
when was the last time a new piece of
equipment was bought in this kitchen
then they never put a nickel into this
place peter is a lot more proud of his
car than is his [ __ ] restaurant
absolutely
that kitchen is the heart of the
restaurant when that's hurt it's like a
clogged artery you're gonna have a big
problem
with so much of the kitchen equipment
not working it's almost impossible for
the chefs to do their jobs and their
frustration has been felt by the rest of
the staff
where's my uh portofino they're coming
but don't keep asking for them don't ask
for them one more [ __ ] time when
there's a chaotic night here i have
robert screaming when the fishes are
ready that's when they're gonna come out
he's an excellent chef but he's crazy
take them take this out [ __ ] gotta
keep asking for the [ __ ] food
can you see if my friend the doctor
wants another bottle of wine on um sure
yeah maybe folks another bottle of wine
on peter you all right who's got sweet
cards
i'll buy them or uh after they drink
coffee
is the doctor come tonight is he the dad
the doctors can't do you take care of it
personally or did you put on the
business
goes off the top it's an expanse
how can i not i mean the guy you know
takes care of me it's only business
i think they said that in the guard
fraud
i [ __ ] charge my doctor trust me he
earns enough yeah it's like a little
meeting place here a little place yeah
shame no one's spending money
the combination of peter spending a
great deal of money on himself and
giving away free meals has put the
family business in jeopardy
and brought a debt collector to the door
the guy you
know
[Music]
what
yeah he'd like no not right now i don't
buddy no no not right now as soon as you
got a minute yeah okay as soon as you
got a minute tell them
go [ __ ] yourself get the [ __ ] out of
here
pick your [ __ ] hands up john guy pick
your [ __ ] hands up you want to hit me
you're the tougher you want to hit me
put your hands on me no no no no i'll
let you do it first listen to me tough
guy no you're the tournament guy our
friendship is [ __ ] way my friend
you're a scumbag
you're always going to scumbag you
[ __ ] talk to me like that again you
get hurt you'll get [ __ ] hurt yeah
you ain't got me scared you ain't got me
scared bro yeah this one don't [ __ ]
no
i spoke to other people too that he's in
debt with that called me up and said if
there's anything i could do i just
wanted to talk to him now wasn't the
time
[Music]
after peter's brush with an overzealous
debt collector gordon checks in with his
sister restaurant owner tina i know i've
just arrived but
[ __ ] me how do you manage oh i'm
motivated by all the nice people that
come in to visit me
but other than that i'm having a
breakdown tell me your biggest
frustration what's the one big issue
that you have from the kitchen to my
brother just it seems like it's only
like a free-for-all like everyone's just
doing what they want i get so
exasperated sometimes so stressed out
that i want to cry or commit bloody
murder but does peter play a part in the
financial side he'll take his paycheck
but not come in i come in and i'll
they'll tell me oh peter took two
hundred dollars
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's like
i didn't even [ __ ] break even for the
day and he took money
you can't do that
how long can you continue functioning
like this with this longer and i can't i
can't do it either i would sooner sell
the business i'm not a martyr i feel
like i'm doing it on my own and that's
the part about it i resent it's not fair
if this doesn't work you know what's at
stake in terms of you know how much
would you lose my house
your house
this is crazy because the true
definition of a family business is every
member of that family working within
to make it successful not one person
carrying the burden
i know
it's day three and time for gordon to
give the family a much-needed wake-up
call
this business was set up 17 years ago as
a family business yes yes
today we're gonna renew that commitment
we're gonna make it more family than
ever before this is what we're going to
do you yeah with your father i'm going
to go and run the kitchen
you're going to cook
you're going to run the kitchen
i love it
hey vay
i want you to go and work in that
kitchen and just experience what it's
like behind that line and work with your
dad you like food you certainly eat
enough of it here tina you're gonna run
the dining room with your mum okay get
in the kitchen and get familiar with
what's going on
peter i've never seen coke well i've
never seen them boiling eggs look at me
i'm looking shaking find it i'm [ __ ]
shaking if you're not shaking enough
let's go come on huh peter's like one of
those guys he eats out a lot so he
assumes he knows about cooking in
restaurants he has no clue about the
kitchen hello
welcome
while peter and his father are settling
into the kitchen why is this burning
uncle lower welcome to my world gordon
is packing the dining room with hungry
customers first order's coming in
standby can i start with you yeah sure
what would you like
do me a favor make me an espresso please
go make it yourself i just want my
mother get me espresso when i'm ready
espresso
is he always like this yeah huh is he
my god if my dad and my brother were the
chefs i think there'd be a mass murderer
in here
i have an order
all aboard the first order's in i need
black olives and artichokes right
underneath here could someone set the us
up oh hold on now it's them that didn't
set you up properly not like that i'm
having a meltdown here are we ready to
order do you need a few minutes can i
have a [ __ ] working oven those are
the ones i ordered already that clams
and the soup
what the [ __ ] is that
this is a a [ __ ] back here
angela table seven please my darling
tin coming in the door where are the
clams where's the salmon where's my
lemons we're shouting for lemons and
look there's a [ __ ] box of lemons
here i need clean spoons i need clean
spoons i need chicken i need chicken
what's that in front of your eyes oh
okay
peter is he's a 250 pound spoiled baby
holy [ __ ] these two didn't get
distractions earlier with their plans uh
tell them about why i'm concerned they
don't need advertisers no bill you have
to get them out what do you want me to
do i can do what i can do at the moment
okay let's put the cat amongst the
pigeons peter is now getting a taste of
his own medicine he's now seen how
difficult it is to cook in that kitchen
with nothing that works so this is
embarrassing because this should have
been a family close-knit tight run
restaurant
it's an hour into lunch service and
there's still no food coming out of the
kitchen it's done what's burning in here
we just burnt the chicken we're the
[ __ ] weed we just couldn't handle it
i don't know i'm looking for a corner to
hide somewhere could someone get me tina
please i need orange juice you want tina
to stop now and get you a glass orange
juice do i have anybody that can help me
look at you
[ __ ] yourself
what
i beg your pardon ooh
take it easy take it easy killer
i want to see what big boy's made of
come on
let's go yeah yeah let's go big boy
relax
finally someone told him listen buddy
don't act like you're you're the king
over here because you got nothing you
get the [ __ ] out of here out robert back
on here please let's go god unbelievable
now gordon has proved his point about
the inadequate kitchen he realizes that
he has to do something drastic to get
the restaurant ready to be relaunched
gordon did you know attack peter in the
right way because he saw him as being
you know a big shot a guy trying to act
like a big shot would you do me a favor
oh yeah we go out go get some fresh air
or go get a [ __ ] manicure polish your
wheels or do something
it's day four and although peter's
attitude to work has been a
disappointment gordon has no choice but
to introduce the first phase of his
transformation plan right today is a new
beginning a new chapter for peter's
restaurant yes yes
the one thing that really needs to take
place here is a commitment
we're gonna implement changes
follow me please yeah through to the
kitchen
welcome to your new kitchen
oh my god
oh man
holy
bro have a look have a look have a look
gordon brought in a team of kitchen
specialists who worked all night to give
this restaurant something it sorely
needed a proper kitchen
every oven is working oh my god
[Music]
plates stoves ovens mats
i can't believe it a new double fridge
as well
oh my god what yes proper working fridge
yes
what a kitchen i think we were all
starting to lose steam here and give up
and and he he brought us back to uh a
sunny day
your new kingdom this is really a good
thing
now i can really have a real kitchen
where i can actually do things the right
way i've invested in this
now i want to see you
with opportunity comes responsibility
and i think that's what gordon was
trying to point out you know what i've
given you what you asked for now you're
responsible to use it respectfully
[Music]
it's time for the chefs and gordon to
put the new kitchen to good use as
gordon starts to change the menu here we
go
i want to focus on family style dining
we're going to be making simple stunning
classic italian foods
okay lasagna i'm very excited tonight to
cook with gordon definitely an honor to
cook with someone like him
i fell into a bit of a rut culinarily
and now that gordon's giving me this new
menu to work with it's a revitalizing
kind of feeling you know
let's go
gordon introduces a new family style
menu that will make peter's restaurant
stand out from the competition
there's what six seven italian
restaurants out there in babylon
one thing
that can separate this restaurant from
the others is running this like a true
family restaurant gordon came about the
idea of family style which i think is an
exceptional idea we needed something to
help us stand out
for tonight's dinner service the parsley
covered ravioli and the cold crab cakes
have been replaced by fresh homemade
family style dishes such as
lobster ravioli the penne lasagna
grilled flank steak cappellini and
norchetta and then porchetta which is
beautiful you know these are dishes that
are popular this is now a time for you
to sort of really seriously start
getting that message out there it's so
simple
okay guys we've got a a a big
big big big launch
yeah big time
[Music]
with a brand new kitchen
a redesigned menu
and a new approach that reaches out to
families the restaurant is ready for its
big relaunch let's do it
[Music]
with the doors about to open gordon
gathers the staff for a last minute pep
talk okay
tonight
is a critical crucial night
are you with us or you i'm just waiting
for him okay we're right really busy
right now
once again peter has a debt collector on
his doorstep
well you are interfering that's what i'm
saying
hey would you mind
you gotta wait too much i gotta talk to
you
get out of the way what why don't you go
away so we can go on
oh wait a minute
why don't you go no get out of the way i
don't want to talk to you i'm saying go
away
yeah
oh no relax relax relax
[Applause]
my father
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] this guy
[ __ ] this guy come on you fake [ __ ]
gangster you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're embarrassing me [ __ ] this guy go
inside
i'm gonna pee the peter relax relax
relax
right now right now
hey come on baby boy take it easy come
in here come here come on come on
come here come and kill me he's sent
five guys to his house right now jeremy
and guys are on their way right now who
the [ __ ] is it
give me this valley
it's the last [ __ ] that's coming in
this place you're getting [ __ ]
hot-headed did you see my father on the
floor no so what do you mean i'm getting
hot insane relaxed
calm down calm down calm down hey
i told him to get out are you okay they
fight a lot
you know these things happen relax relax
relax relax
let's see aside few seconds walk fresh
air come on with me let's go
what's going on what happened
don't conduct that in my business no no
you're right that's first of all second
of all i didn't like the way he spoke to
you he's just his back foot
relax relax relax relax
big deep breath yeah
i'm here to help
the row has wasted crucial preparation
time now gordon urgently needs to get
peter and the staff focused on tonight's
relaunch
big big big night i mean a seriously big
night yeah new menu
new family style dining new attitude
this
could be the big turning point for this
restaurant
use this opportunity to show off
how good we can be
[Music]
good
luck there's excitement in the
restaurant about the new menu
do the fish it's excellent
i like the idea
but back in the kitchen it's up to the
chefs to deliver
the big tables are all ordering family
style now all of a sudden we're working
with all this new stuff
it's like alien may i have a uh
cranberry juice salsa and cranberry
actually you know what you have
pineapple juice yeah give me pineapple
juice with a lot of ice and a splash of
cranberry it's good for my sugar
it's one hour into dinner service and
the restaurant has not been this full
for seven years
let's set this up for 14 right now come
on come on come on
right now they've got a 14 top just
arrived and this is a true test now
because family style should make their
life a lot easier or it can go tits up
and be a disaster it's so busy tina tina
you have a throat lozenger
peter as an owner he should step up to
you know move his ass a little bit more
because he's in la la land i don't know
what to do
this table right here yeah bring him an
appetizer too
but when peter does decide to lend a
hand hungry man
instead of serving the bait clams you
got a fork back here anybody got a fork
come on i want to see him gordon see me
eating i don't want to get yelled at
he decides to eat them
oh man
peter excuse me peter i got to ask you
for one favorite delicious correct
anything
robert what what the [ __ ] is going on
here nothing you're hungry yeah
go look at your stomach in the window
let's go
yeah we need another dozen day clams one
of yours went out
still waiting on my baked clams all
right i'll take care of you with that
i'll bring a small
guys should i come should i come back
next week for the bay clam should i go
down the block for the other restaurant
i promise you'll you'll have it
okay dining is filling up new menu new
kitchen new family style dining but
peter it's mike and sam right now noah
honey i'll take a cappuccino if you can
make me with two equals please it it was
really difficult i mean you know in my
legs hurt my tired it's it was harder
than the gym it was really harder than
the gym when gordon puts the pressure on
peter
[Music]
no one came to your table yeah
nicole are you kidding me you go to
these people's table that wasn't
supposed to be my table i don't care
what we're supposed to be taking right
now right now he was yelling at me in
front of my customers for things that
i didn't do wasn't supposed to be my
table imagine this it's hard for him to
you know realize that he did something
wrong so he takes it out on everybody
else get them one bottle on me right now
for all your comedy of errors tonight
thank you so you cost me a bottle of
wine
just get them the bottle of wine please
but i don't know why peter's temper's
like that [ __ ] [ __ ]
i mean he's in everybody's way everybody
else just brushes it off but i guess i
just
take it a little personal when he's
screaming at me if on my table so
what the [ __ ] is going on with a7 and
everything what
tables that said stuff to me like oh wow
he's being hard on you
hot on you you're very happy
how can i be a hot person to talk to
that's ridiculous
well if you need to talk to me i would
rather talk to me like that kid how
could you cry
she was like uh a machine gun she just
started shooting all this stuff out she
looked like she was having some sort of
uh meltdown i don't make the jigs i
don't make the food this is ridiculous
here hey hold on a minute you're
embarrassing me relax
just turn it down a bit just turn on the
puppy hey
oh my god i never seen something like
this
[Music]
thank you very much thank you thank you
with over 200 satisfied customers the
relaunch is a success
in spite of nato this place was a
success and has now pissed through your
hands
well it is what it it it is what it is
you've neglected it i understand but
right now we're not in a situation
money-wise to fix it well [ __ ] me what's
the time
what do you think this is your [ __ ]
little salon to get your massage and get
fed
you're [ __ ] walking around this place
with a bowl of food in your [ __ ] hand
eating away
[Music]
that's not how i run my [ __ ] business
i'm getting a [ __ ] headache
i just think you've seen him day's work
for [ __ ] 20 years yeah i i've had my
own personal
problems we all have problems problem
problem problem problem problem you're
no different
let's
start working at the problem what's the
problem what's the problem
you that's where i'm starting excuse me
[Music]
he [ __ ] nuts this guy you're right
i'm [ __ ] nuts because you've got [ __ ]
all to worry about right now have you
listen to me i'm [ __ ] listening
listen to me you sound like you're out
the [ __ ] godfather
yeah what the [ __ ] is going on here
you're the only [ __ ] here right now
is not pulling their weight and that's
not [ __ ] good enough
i think this place will run better
without you
[Music]
i i i i disagree you disagree i'll own
certain problems and i'll take
responsibility for a lot of things that
was about as convincing as a [ __ ]
person
[Music]
i need two minutes with you on your own
you go all right i'll see you in the
morning
i love him
tonight
go home and come back tomorrow morning
and think about what are you going to
put back into the business tomorrow
think about it
and make sure it's [ __ ] good
because i'm going to be here to make
sure you do it
i i'm never speechless i don't know what
to say
[Music]
i'm i'm like i'm a little hurt
what i'm seeing now is
he said to me everything all these
people wanted to say to me and haven't
so maybe gordon's right you know what
i'm not gonna say maybe gordon's right
gordon is right
i'm committed i'll be back and i'll do
what he says it's for the good of the
business and in the end this place is me
this place is me this is me this is what
i do so i gotta make it work
[Music]
to gordon's amazement the next morning
he found peter on the phone calling to
fix the walk-in fridge
we need our walk-in box fixed
leaking here
there's like oh she has rain water
i want you to come here and uh do
whatever it needs to have done i'm
really amazed that peter is taking the
initiative and putting the new walking
box
and to go with the brand new kitchen
robert and john have a new attitude
i'm very excited i think everything's
going so well uh-huh
family style's working wow yeah yeah and
the family style dining is a huge hit
with customers
[Applause]
i haven't had
with word of mouth spreading profits are
soaring the end of the night we made
more money we made more money this way
it's unbelievable as soon as they calm
down i'll show you
[Music]
to reach out to the local community
peter's hosted the first ever babylon
family day
holy cow look at this
[Music]
this is a huge great start to to push
the new family theme
come and my family will serve yours
to make the relaunch complete peter
decided the restaurant needed one more
thing
the father may the blessing of almighty
god the father the son the holy spirit
this was a rebirth so
it needed its blessing can i hug you
please i gotta think about hogan father
in the weeks ahead peter was more
helpful
yeah i'll get some extra plates too okay
he made amends with nicole
i'm sorry i'm sorry all right my
priorities were mixed up instead of
trying to be like you know the boss i'm
going to be a team player here and
whatever needs to be done i'm going to
i'm going to jump in i'm going to ask
people if they need help with things
there you go enjoy i like that shirt
and even provided tina with the help she
needed i mean i'm thrilled i even think
peter will do his part i really do think
he's going to keep his commitment i'm
sorry all right i love you i love you
too
let's just confirm one thing shall we
we've got a taste of how good
this ration can be absolutely and just
comparing to what i experienced the
first time i arrived here tonight
the difference was night and day
before gordon got here this place was
nose diving the man
reinvented my restaurant i think now
he's given us all our spark back if you
cannot make this work you're mad
you've got a potential gold mine here
that can make every one of you
successfully [ __ ] rich
we are definitely on our way to success
here now we have to take the ball and
run with it thank you for the commitment
yeah
yeah we've been given all the help in
the world time for us to shine and we
got what we need
and i'm ready to do it
[Music]
all of gordon's ideas stemmed to keep
this restaurant synonymous with family
we all love each other so that's my main
ingredient now for the restaurant
and i think that's so important three
thousand dollars
for all that extra
material take care
i really fell in love with him my first
son is going to be named after gordon
gordon ramsay pellegrino gordon really
brought our family much closer together
hi buddy yes thank you
at this time they can stay together and
commit to this restaurant it will be
successful but
stop the [ __ ] fighting
[Music]